NE mus said something really interesting
and it's kind of touchy subject so just
bear with me the way I tried to
paraphrase this he basically said that
death is good the reason he said that
death is good is because it allows new
ideas to come that's what he said okay I
know it's it's a little harsh but that's
what he said so back to the coffee shop
example right now yeah it's only Bitcoin
Fanatics that accept Bitcoin um at these
coffee shops I agree with you but as
this new generation who really
understand digital technology genz as we
become older we approach our 30s our 40s
or 50s we are going to be doing business
in Bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies
right now I actually pay people in
Bitcoin